I mean I did a movie with Matt Damon we
did a Good Shepherd that DeNiro directed
and they'd say cut now I knew that Bob
Richardson one of the most legendary
cinematographers in history you know
Oscars movies with Marty legend they
would talk Bob and both Bob's and then
DeNiro would come over to me and Matt
and give us these notes and I would just
stare at him and literally like after 60
seconds I'd be like could you say that
again because I haven't heard a single
word you said I've been too busy staring
at you I'm just staring at you and all
I'm seeing is you know movies and movies
and movies and movie regimen oh you're
one of the greatest movie stars that
ever lived in history right and you're
standing in front of me and you know
walk up and go to be very good a
litigant and I just sit there staring
I'm going I mean I'm so you're right
because it's narrow
yeah but chinotto all the people you
love Beatty everybody you love you don't
get intimidated when you work with
uncles I do yeah
and crazy yeah but you gotta do what you
have to do you got to get over that